بَابَا بابا جَالِسْ وَاقِفْ
لَا يَتْرُكُ مِنْ يَدِهِ الهَاتِفْ
وَاتْسابْ مَاسِنْجَرْ فَيسْبُوكْ
مَا عَادَ يُلاَعِبُ وَيُلاَطِفْ
بَابَا بابا جَالِسْ وَاقِفْ
لَا يَتْرُكُ مِنْ يَدِهِ الهَاتِفْ
بَابَا بَابَا جَرَحْتُ ذِراعي
أه أه
لَا تَفْزَعْ ابْني لاَ دَاعِي
مَامَا في المَطْبَخِ أَخْبِرْهَا
سَتَعْمَلُ مَا يَلْزَمْ وَتُرَاعِي
بَابَا بابا جَالِسْ وَاقِفْ
لَا يَتْرُكُ مِنْ يَدِهِ الهَاتِفْ
بَابَا بَابَا أَنَا جَوْعَانْ
مَامَا تَطْبُخُ بَعْدَ ثَوَانْ
سَتَأْتِي بِطَعَامٍ فاصْبِرْ
فَقَطْ اتْرُكْنِى وَحْدِي الآَنْ
هيا اتْرُكْنِى
بَابَا بابا هَيَّا نَلْعَبْ
نَصْرُخُ تَجْعَلُ وَجْهَكَ مُرْعِبْ
نَجْرِى وَتَجْرِى لِتُلاَحِقَنَا
يَمْضِى الوَقْتُ مَعَكَ مُحَبَّبْ
هيا يا بابا
يَا أولادي أَنَا مَشْغُولْ
هَذَا عملي مَاذَا أَقُولْ
أولادي أَنَا مَشْغُولْ
أَتَصَفَّحُ بِالنَّتِ أَجُولْ
أَنَا مَشْغُولْ
بَابَا بابا جَالِسْ وَاقِفْ
لَا يَتْرُكُ مِنْ يَدِهِ الهَاتِفْ
وَاتْسابْ مَاسِنْجَرْ فَيسْبُوكْ
مَا عَادَ يُلاَعِبُ وَيُلاَطِفْ
بَابَا بابا جَالِسْ وَاقِفْ
لَا يَتْرُكُ مِنْ يَدِهِ الهَاتِفْ
زَوْجي قَسَّمْ وَقْتَكْ
نَحْتَاجُكَ مَعَنَا ونُحِبُّكْ
العَمَلُ مُهِمٌ نَتَفَهَّمْ
لَكِنْ أَيْضَاً نَحْنُ نَهُمُكْ
نُحِبُك يا بابا
بابا امْنَحْنَا بَعْضَ الوَقْتْ
ثُمَّ اذهب واعْمَلْ مَا شِئْتْ
اُحْضُنَّا بَابَا دَاعِبْنَا
هَذَا مَا نَطْلُبُ أَفَهِمْتْ
حَسَنَاً حَسَنًا يَا أولادي
هيا نَلْعَبُ حادي بَادِى
أَنْتُمْ بِالدُّنْيَا أَحْبابي
ضِحْكَتُكُمْ مَصْدَرُ إسْعادي
هييييييييييييييييييي